For the coefficients, we just divide them. We know 8 divided by 2 makes 4. For
the bases of x, however, we want to subtract their exponents. We have 7 minus
positive 1, which is 6. Another way to think about it is we would have x to the
6th left in the numerator. So 4x to the 6th is our first term. 6x to the 4th
would be our second term. 12 divded by 2 makes 6. And x to the 5th divided by x
to the 1 makes x to the 4th. Our last term should be negative 3x squared. 6
divided by 2 equals negative 3. We know it's negative because the sign is
negative. And then x to the 3rd divided by x to the 1 is x squared, or x to the
2nd. Here's the answer to dividing this polynomial. Great work if you got it
right.